this NATO pact that's been much aborted
in the media with Ukraine is being led
by the UK France and Germany let's be
clear this is not about joining NATO
this is about coordinating military
support for the forthcoming fighting
season make sure Ukraine gets the right
equipment at the right time this spring
offensive could be decisive and if it
was the West's support is only limited
in the long term and therefore could
potentially Drive Putin to the
negotiating table challenges negotiation
is all about compromise at the moment
there doesn't seem to be any appetite
from either side for compromise this
group though is probably also looking at
the long-term security guarantees that
Ukraine might need once the war
eventually ends now Western support for
Ukraine has proven absolutely vital and
if this spring offensive is to Prevail
the supplies of Western weapons are key
there's reports coming in now that
Poland has been the first to deliver its
Leopard 2 tanks which is really positive
news however on the flip side it looks
likely that American Abraham's tanks may
not arrive for up to a year the issue of
jets as well is something that keeps
cropping up president zielinski keeps
asking for Western f-16s the West keeps
saying no however it does look likely
now that the West recognizes that
Ukraine will need robust air power in
the medium to long term and the
provision of trained pilots will be one
of the longest lead items there and that
is why the UK has agreed to start
training Pilots the big concern here on
the weapons front though is China it
looks likely that China is considering
whether to send armed drones in support
of Russia plus some artillery and
weapons to date they've sat on the fence
but if they were to start providing
weapons to China that will be a
dangerous escalation but turning to the
one-year anniversary most analysts
including myself was expecting at that
anniversary some big major speech from
Putin and a major Battlefield success by
Russia on the ground neither really
happened but it's worth noting that
Putin had in in the past asked when
Russia had taken house on had said that
is Russia forever Weeks Later the
Russians left likewise he said that the
donbass will be Russian forever before
they'd taken it and still despite many
months and hundreds of thousands of
lives that has still not gone either so
it looks likely that Putin had uh took a
much more measured view aiming his
rhetoric at domestic Russian audience
and preparing them for the long term but
potentially also with an eye on China
trying to drag China into this war as
Russia will recognize how decisive that
could be